over the hump
so
you are
the best chess player in the world
and you not playing the world
championship really
makes the world championship not seem
important or i mean there's an argument
to be made for that is there anything
you would like to see if you had a
change about the world championship that
would make it more fun for you and
better for the game of chess period for
everybody involved so i think 12 games
or now 14 games that there is for the
world championship is a fairly
fairly low sample size if you want to
determine who the best player is or at
least the best player in that particular
match up you need more more games and i
think to some extent
if you're gonna have a world champion
and call them the best players you best
player you gotta make sure that the
format
increases the chance of finding
finding the best player so i think
having more games
and if you're gonna have a lot more
games than you need to
then you need to decrease the time
control a bit
which
in turn i think is also
a good thing because
in very long time controls with
deep preparation you can sort of mask a
lot of your deficiencies as
as as a chess player um with because you
have
a lot of time to to think and to defend
and also
yeah you have the preparation um
so i think those would be
for me to play um those would be
the the main the main um the main things
more
more games and less time so you want to
see more games
and uh rules that emphasize pure chess
yeah but already
less time emphasize
emphasizes pure pure chess because
um
defensive techniques are are much harder
to execute with a little time what do
you think is there a sweet spot in terms
of are we talking about blitz is it how
many places a bit too fast um
to their credit this was suggested by by
feed as well
for a start to have two games per day
and let's say you have
45 minutes a game plus
15 or 30 seconds per move that means
that each sessions will probably be
about
or a little less than two hours yeah
that would be would be a start also
what's
what we're playing in the tournament
that i'm playing here in
in in miami which is um four games a day
uh with 15 minutes plus 10 seconds per
move
those were would be um more interesting
than than the one
there is now and i i understand that
there are a lot of traditions people
don't want to change the world
championship that's that's all fine i
just think that um
the world championship
should do a better job of trying to
reflect who who's the best overall chess
player
so would you would you say like
if it's faster games you'd probably be
able to get a sample size of like
over 20 games 20 30 40 do you think
there's a number that's good over a long
period of time well i would prefer as
many as possible so like a hundred
um yeah but let's say you play 12 days
two games a day you know that's 24. yeah
i feel like that's already quite a bit
better you play like one black game one
white game
each day endurance wise that's okay yeah
i think that's fine like you will have
three days as well so i don't think that
will be will be a problem
um and also you have to prepare two sets
of openings for each day which makes it
more difficult for the teams preparing
which i think is also good